US President Donald Trump is trying on a
new label for his withdrawal from
northern Syria strategically brilliant
in two appearances with the Italian
president Trump went on to list a series
of falsehoods quickly dismissed by
senators from his own political party
Kurds are much safer right now one of
the things that I think we could
tragically see emerge as the potential
for ethnic cleansing and against Kurds
now if you look at the Kurds and again I
say this with great respect they're no
angels I want to express my gratitude to
the Kurds they were great fighters and
we had a terrific alliance with them
Russia wants nothing to do with Isis
Russia's tough they can kill Isis just
as well to rely on Russia and Iran to
protect us against the rise of Isis is
quite frankly insane we may know more
about how the president framed the issue
to president Erdogan in this leaked
letter Trump writes quote history will
look upon you favorably if you get this
done the right and humane way it will
look upon you forever as the devil if
good things don't happen don't be a
tough guy don't be a fool they did go to
other countries and with his vice
president in the audience just hours
from heading to Turkey to demand a
ceasefire the president sent this
message Turkey and Syria will hopefully
work it out between themselves so now
what's next well all eyes will be on
vice president Mike Pence as he heads to
Turkey to ask for a ceasefire that
experts say much less likely to happen
now given the president's comments the
US House of Representatives in an
overwhelming vote passed a resolution
condemning the president's move and
they're threatening quick sanctions on
Turkey if they don't agree to a
ceasefire something the vice president
will ask for even though it now appears
the president that is sending him
doesn't necessarily think the US should
be involved at all patty :
al Jazeera Washington